hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that pretty much just finished
uh from the Tata steel India Blitz
section it is
Arjun irrigation and here uh it would we
would have to say that neuterbeck is the
favorite to win this even though he has
a lower rapid rating as he is the world
rapid Champion but this is an incredible
tournament with 10 incredibly strong
players five Indians five non-indians
and anything can happen but this is
Blitz in the rapid however uh notice
didn't do so so great out of the 10
players he got seventh place uh the
tournament Was Won by nihal sarin with
six and a half points and the Arjun here
uh won second place with with six points
another back in in seventh with um well
basically shared third the seventh with
four four and a half points but this is
blitz so let's see how they how they did
in this one it's a wild game and uh so
many lines could have gone differently
but you just don't have time to analyze
them we have E4 by noderbeck and Arjun
goes for Pawn to E6 the French defense
is on the board and of course whenever
we show the French you know that it's
going to be a good one we have D for D5
uh Pawn to E5 going for the advanced
variation against the French and now C5
striking against White Center Knight to
F3 with Knight to C6 and now Bishop to
D3 the the so-called names of each
system Bishop to D7 we have castles and
Knight G to E7 now this is a new move uh
usually you your options here are
basically C captures and the four Knight
captures or you advance this Pawn to the
C4 but Arjun thought let's try something
tricky against another back in this one
he played Knight gt7 and it is now
already as of move 6 that we have a
completely new game so here Rook to E1
we have C for now forcing the bishop
back but luckily
um our Rook D1 was played to make the F1
Square available for the bishop we have
Knight to F5 Knight to C3 and now you
don't want to allow whites to dislodge
this knight from F5 at any point so Pawn
to H5 and once you see this you can see
why it's so tricky to play uh the French
and white so tricky to play against the
French look at this beautiful Knight on
F5 what opening do you play to have such
a beautiful night uh already on move
nine I mean it it can it can't be
disliked from there it's just a
spectacular piece so here Knight the E2
and now Bishop to E7 we have knighted
the G3 and now Arjun starts the attack
Pawn to G5 and how do you how do you
counter this uh Knight captures on F5
this has to be played e captures and now
Pawn to H4 this is a very good reply by
another but now if G4 not just Knight G5
and the Knight is a very well I defended
there and it's an excellent piece so
after H4 G cap is an H4 grabbing that
one so it ruins um
urgent spawn structure a little bit but
you got the semi-openg file for the
attack so it's all it's all good uh
Bishop to F4 uh we have Bishop to E6 and
now Pawn to B3 now another week has to
figure out how to open up the center and
he will do so by countering the the C4
Pawn with the B Pawn uh Rook to G8 we
have B captures and C for D captures and
now Rook to B1 going after the B7 Pawn
so Queen to D7 and now Pawn to C3 now
white has a very strong Center
uh but still it's a question how how to
actually do something about it black has
a very very nice control over the D5
Square B7 is defended and it's uh well
it's just hard to find a way through for
white here Bishop to D5 this is now a
beautiful Bishop going after that the G2
Pawn you know the black and always
Castle Queen side he he can double up on
the G file the queen can enter the game
between E6 Queen G6 so white has to
figure out something here uh Rook the B5
a very nice Rook lift by white also
putting pressure on that Bishop you
constantly have to check if Rook will
capture Bishop uh as there might be some
tricks in the position we have rooked
the G4 uh Arjun also finds a very nice
Rook lift and now Bishop back to H2 uh
here you could go for real characters on
D5 it's uh because Black's position is
so powerful that this uh might be the
way to go and now after okay your Bishop
is still attacked Bishop to C1 and now
once black castles to bring the Rook
into the attack you go Knight H2 attack
The Rook ones the rule goes back you
play Queen capture Sun H5 and you might
find uh some some counter play here you
do have the semi-open B file you do have
the very strong Center uh you've slowed
the blacks attack a little bit now the
the light Square Bishop no longer exists
uh it's still better for black but white
will be able to play this however in the
game after Rook G4 Bishop to H2 was
played and now Arjun castles Queen side
and here Rook to E3 and Rook to E3 is
not the greatest of moves uh there are
there are many ways you can go about
this but there is one that just
completely gives black a winning
position so feel free to pause the video
and try to figure this out while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the
winning idea and for those of you who
just won't enjoy the show it is Knight
captures on D4 it was not played in the
game but now that you see it of course
it makes sense The Rook on B5 is
undefended and now there really isn't
all that much to do if if white throws
in a nice in between move you throw in a
nice in between move with the check as
well so basically the line is Knight
captures on D4 Rook captures on D4 the
first before recapturing on B5 C
captures now Queen captures on B5 and
there's just nothing for white to do
here black is just so much better
whatever you do let's say we attack the
queen queen C6 now the queen and Bishop
around this diagonal The Rook is coming
to G8 uh the pawns pawns are Marching
forward there's just no way to stop a
Black's attack here but okay Arjun finds
the next best idea Ponte for he probably
was thinking about Pawn to F4 all the
time and then he just didn't spot that
the The Rook here was undefended uh Rook
back the E1 as The Rook really had no
place being on E3 and now Rook D to G8
uh over here Knight captures or even
Bishop captures on F3 followed by Knight
captures on D4 Again The Rook is
undefended you can take advantage of
this uh this way but Rook D the G8 Arjun
continues playing his game and King the
H1 just nicely getting away from that g
file A6 chases away The Rook even helps
uh White in in a way and now Rook
captures on D5 you don't really have a
good way if you go back Rook to B1 uh
just H3 and you can you can resign here
there's really nothing you can do if you
capture G captures on H3 uh then this
opens up the G file is now open there's
really nothing you don't even need to
rush it you can just go back and enjoy
your position I mean disgusting for
white so after this A6 move Rook
captures on the five negative access
alright this is uh not even an exchange
sacrifice I mean that that Bishop was
much stronger than that Rook Queen
captures on D5 and now Pawn to A4 we
have Bishop to d8 Shifting the bishop
into the attack as well and Quinta E2
now hoping to get a queen trade in with
Queen to E4 Knight to A5 and now Rook to
B1 uh we have Bishop to C7 and now Rogue
back to E1 another back repeating moves
not still ready to go for that Queen
trade and now King to B8 uh improving
the position of the king Rook the B1 we
have kinked the A8 and now Rook back to
E1 and Rook to G6 and now you really
have to go for Queen T for uh otherwise
you know that Rook to G6 is coming and
then a nice Rook lift probably over uh
to B3 going after that weakness C3 pawn
and uh Queen E4 is well the only thing
left for white it was not played in the
game but uh just to give you an example
captures captures maybe Rook B6 going
for for B3 for B2 uh black is much
better but maybe white can defend
however in the game night the G1 was
played nor the back offers the G2 Pawn
for some counter play but it's a very
very hard to play this Rook captures on
G2 was played now you can't recapture
because of Checkmate so you have to play
Knight to F3 now okay The Rook is
hanging but just Rook back to G4
and black now just enjoys uh a fully
open G file as well Queen to E4 offering
a queen trade but Arjun shows that
um he can trade this and still be better
captures captures we have Rook the B6
not trying to go for the C Pawn Rook to
E1 and now Rook the B2 first going after
the F2 pawn bishop to G1 defending and
now Rook to C2 going after the pawn from
behind the stopping Rook to C1 and now
D5 uh giving up some material to start
advancing those pawns Rook captures on
C3 Pawn to D6 now Bishop to d8 and now
Knight to D4 with Bishop to B6 putting
pressure on the Knight here and Knight
to F5 we have H3 and now Bishop to E2
attacking The Rook Rook the G5 attacks
the Knight and Knight the E7 so Ken
white Advance those pawns or is black
just Unstoppable in the game Rook
captures an E5 happened Rook to D1
putting the Rook behind the pass Pawn
but now just to Rook captures I need to
grabbing that free Bishop Knights the D5
now with a double attack and the bishop
and The Rook here Rook to D3 and Knight
captures and B6 with check King V8
uh we have rooked the C1 uh and now Rook
captures on D6 we have Ponte f a pawn to
F3 by white Rook to C6 uh and now you
could uh also capture the Knight here
but I know you guys forgot about our
good friend the bishop on G1 so Rook to
C6 and now Rook to D1 we have Rook seat
the E6 doubling up on the E file and now
rooked d8 with check another back tries
one last trick because if you go to A7
it's possible to forget about the bishop
I mean it is possible then Rook day it
will be Checkmate however in the game
King the C7 was played with Rook to D5
now saying okay you capture my knight
I'm gonna capture uh your your knight on
A5 but uh Rook captures some B6 and he
was in this position unmove uh 50 that
nother back up to Saturn resigned in the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here the problem is if you capture the
Knight and if you don't you're just down
too much material Rook to B1 and you're
getting checkmated nothing to do here
whatever white plays doesn't really
matter just Rook to G2 and the next move
will be checkmate uh so yeah after uh
this wonderful rooked capture some B6
move another back resigned and uh Arjun
takes the lead in the Tata uh well this
is a game from round one so yeah he won
a very nice game and he did win second
place in the rapid section uh so now
starting with a win in the blitz
definitely will go a long way so we'll
see how it goes I will try to cover a
few more games from the blitz section if
you have any favorites do hashtag
suggestion and I will go over them uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done taking down
the world rapid Champion like this uh I
would like to thank Stefan trifonovich
Andres
Zoltan sarkari and Eric Adams for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Tata still India Blitz until it finishes
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day